welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i'm the
host of the show but today i am joined
by a special temporary guest co-host his
name is greg knuckles greg thank you for
joining me thanks for having me on
absolutely
we've got a lot to cover in this episode
uh before we get into all of the
detailed hard-hitting scientific
presentations
start with a couple announcements here
if you enjoy the show and you want to
support it we would have of course
appreciate that you can do that in a
number of different ways you can like
rate and subscribe wherever you happen
to get podcasts
you could go to
bulksupplements.com and use our discount
code sbs pod for a five percent discount
you could subscribe to the mass research
review which we are co-authors of
or you could download the macro factor
diet app which does have a free trial
that is the diet app that we designed
with a very talented team of people
and we'd love for you to check it out
because we think you might like it
uh before we get into the content for
today um
just kind of a a warning here
daylight savings time
has wrecked me like
the clocks moved i guess like a day or
two ago
and it just hits me so hard like i'm a
creature of habit so when the clocks
shift an hour it throws me off so like
today i'm delirious i was doing my
morning emails and made so many insane
they weren't even typos i was just
writing words that didn't make sense and
i would catch it before i sent it but
yeah my brain is just not working so
everything from this point forward
for this episode i'm sorry uh my brain
just doesn't work today i don't know how
you're doing but oh i'm not good i'm
doing great one of the advantages of not
having a schedule really not having a
circadian rhythm at all
is
i'm just
i'm never operating i assume at peak
efficiency but by extension i don't even
notice when
my schedule gets thrown off because it
doesn't it doesn't exist so i think i'm
taking the like tele anti-fragile
approach here um
by just
you know making my life probably 40
percent worse on a day-to-day basis but
then being unaffected
by perturbations like this yeah that's a
nice type of immunity to build up yeah
but yeah today i'm just out of it so
i'm sure i'll misspeak 30 or 40 times in
the next hour but we're gonna push ahead
anyway speaking of sleep and building
immunity uh
we're
two minutes into the episode and already
getting off track but have you ever
heard of the documentary film hands on a
hard body no all right all right so it's
about
uh it's about a contest i think in
arkansas every year um so this is a
documentary an actual documentary um
where
we do often say that when we're talking
about just complete [ __ ] yeah yeah
um so yeah it's just kind of like i
guess like a slice of life human
interest documentary where there's a
contest every year where um
there's a truck and people who want to
win the truck for free just show up
have to keep a hand on it and whoever
can keep a hand on it the longest wins
okay and i think i think they get like
maybe a 30 minute or like a 10 minute
break every
six hours or something to use the
bathroom but like they can't sleep they
can't lay down they have to keep a hand
on this truck and so
the contest runs like
three four days like people go multiple
days without sleeping because they
really want to win this truck
and in the documentary there was one
particular character who
had pulled two consecutive all-nighters
before the uh before the contest started
good play because he believed that
uh you could build up an immunity to
sleep deprivation and so by going two
nights without sleep before the contest
he even started he wasn't putting
himself at a disadvantage he was getting
a head start on his competition
at building up an immunity to sleep
deprivation
and uh he did not win wow that's crazy
yeah who could have predicted that
it's like doing a sport where where
dehydration is a major concern you're
like i'm gonna go ahead and restrict
water for a few days just to get a leg
up yeah yeah um yeah we we both have a
habit of whenever we're talking about a
very stupid untrue thing we call it a
documentary so
it's hard for me to seriously reference
documentaries anymore
um
yeah so
you're doing better than i am but i do
think i'll recover soon good um all
right so road to athens all start uh
nothing too interesting here but i'm
really excited uh i'm gonna start cross
training pretty soon with a little bit
of stand up paddle boarding and i can't
wait i'm excited to have some updates
with that once that starts i'm just
waiting for the lake to kind of get warm
enough to actually go out there and not
like
have hypothermia but
you might recall i talked a lot about
swimming
in the summer in the fall what i was
trying to do is basically
learn how to swim so that i could do
paddle boarding this upcoming year and
not fear that i would like drown from it
so i'm really excited to uh to start
that and it should be within the next uh
the next month or so i think i'll be
able to get out there but other than
that really no updates uh what about you
how is the road to the stage yeah
honestly no no real updates for me
either uh weight's been pretty flat for
the past week or so i think the low 230s
which is where i am now
is treating me about the same way the
low 240s did before just basically
plateauing for a while and you know
hopefully will break through soon um
assuming physics still works
as long as i keep sticking to my diet
yeah things will start moving again so
nothing to report this week but not too
concerned about it
good stuff
all right so
obviously
uh last episode i had a short segment
that lasted basically the whole episode
it uh it really got away from me there
but
uh we want to make sure that you're able
to do your rese research roundup with no
interruptions uh take as much time as
you need it looks like you're gonna be
talking about walking and health
i will yeah yeah so um
hopefully this doesn't run quite as long
as the intended short segment on the
last episode yeah uh because i do have a
very good to play us out bit of content
and i don't want to feel rushed when we
get there um but yeah so i'm going to be
talking about walking a little bit uh
specifically so
we published a research brief in mass
which we then shared to the website and
instagram uh maybe like a month ago
a month or two ago there abouts and i'm
pretty sure we talked about it on the
podcast already
but just a little refresher before
diving into the actual meat of this
segment
so it was a research brief uh based on a
recent meta-analysis by giadi and
colleagues the title was daily step
count and all calls mortality a dose
response meta-analysis of prospective
cohort studies
so there were seven studies included in
this
and what a prospective cohort study
means is that you don't have an
intervention you basically just recruit
a group of subjects and then moving
forward in time you just track what
you're interested in about them so in
this case uh you're keeping track of
step counts and you're keeping track of
mortality like are they alive or dead um
so there were seven prospective cohort
studies in the meta-analysis with a
total of 28 000 participants and about 2
300 of them died over the course of
their respective studies
time span
and the researchers found that the rates
of all calls mortality were about 12
lower per 1000 steps per day
so essentially what that means is that
if you take all else being equal if you
take about 12 000 steps per day more
than another individual you're about 12
percent less likely to die
in that year
so uh one thing to note i
unintentionally used causal language in
that past sentence i shouldn't have this
this was an epi study there was no
intervention wasn't an rct
um so you can't necessarily use causal
language it's just that
walking a thousand steps more per day
was associated with a 12
uh lower lower mortality rate um
and also i think it's worth
it's worth noting the actual magnitudes
in that study because
uh like so just to contextualize it that
was 12
per 1000 steps per day
um and
just to use another
uh kind of point of reference
for how large of a reduction that is
smoking seems to be associated with 70
to 80 percent higher rates of all cause
mortality
so in effect walking
about an extra 7 8 000 steps per day is
a so is associated with a comparable
reduction in all cause mortality rates
as smoking is associated with an
increase in all cause mortality rates so
that's you know all said and told a
pretty big difference
i would say
so anyway i think we've talked about
this on a previous episode
um and since that episode was published
uh and also since we shared this on the
website and on instagram there has been
a single relatively common criticism
that has come up uh and or
criticism slash
line of skepticism which we like on this
show we like skepticism and that is that
the findings of that meta-analysis may
be mere association in other words it's
showing that walking more is associated
with lower rates of alcohol's mortality
but it could simply be that people who
are
generally healthier do tend to walk more
like if someone
might already be in the beginnings of a
disease state they may not be as active
so you know you're basically finding
that walking as a reflector of general
health may be associated with lower
rates of alcohol's mortality but that
doesn't necessarily mean that walking
itself is a causal mechanism to reduce
alcohol's mortality
there's a difference between saying
people who walk more die less and if you
walk more you will be less likely to die
those are two similar but slightly
different statements uh and so that was
a
concern that was raised by quite a few
people about uh that that meta-analysis
that we wrote about
um
so anyway yeah let's let's dive into
that um
i'm gonna talk about some other
intervention well quite a few systematic
reviews and or meta-analyses
and one review paper um
looking at
randomized control trials uh
inter prospective intervention studies
um and just like various lines of
evidence suggesting that the influence
of walking on risk factors of alcohol's
mortality and alcohol's mortality itself
uh that that is likely an actual causal
relationship and not just mere
association so you know basically just
providing more evidence to beef up
something that we've previously talked
about
so uh to start with um
there was a meta-analysis of randomized
control trials by murphy and colleagues
the title was the effect of walking on
fitness fatness and resting blood
pressure a meta-analysis of randomized
control trials and one thing to note
before really diving into this all of
these studies and metas that i'm going
to talk about will be linked in the show
notes if you would like to check them
out
so anyway uh this meta included 24
randomized control trials where walking
was the only intervention in the trial
and it found a significant reduction in
weight and body fat percentage and a
significant improvement in vo2 max just
from walking interventions and it should
be noted the magnitudes of changes
weren't particularly large uh in in the
studies included in this meta you know
we're talking about
uh over
over the course of the interventions
maybe losing like a kilo or two of fat
small reduction in body fat percentage i
think vo2 went up by like three four mls
per kg so we're not talking about
turning people into marathon runners but
a meta-analysis of rcts finding
uh
improvements in in three different
markers that tend to be associated with
longevity and again that that is in rcts
moving on a systematic review by lee and
colleagues the title is the effect of
walking intervention on blood pressure
control a systematic review
uh so
to be included in the systematic review
it needed to be a randomized control
trial with a non-intervention control
group to compare against and study
samples needed to be
people 16 or older and the intervention
needed to predominantly focus on walking
and blood pressure needed to be an
outcome so
this is looking at a risk factor for
specifically cardiovascular disease risk
which
is obviously a predictor of mortality
so there were 27 rcts included in this
systematic review since this wasn't a
meta-analysis it wasn't necessarily
looking for kind of a pooled
effect estimate but just basically
looking at the rcts just the literature
on this topic what are some trends that
you see emerging
so of the 27 uh of the 27 trials
included in the systematic review
nine of them found an effect of the
walking intervention on blood pressure
a beneficial effect and the walking
intervention tends to be effective from
studies with a larger sample size and a
beneficial effect of walking on blood
pressure tended
tended to come from studies that
employed a moderate to high intensity
walking intervention and a longer
intervention period so that's that's a
quote from the abstract basically uh
basically they found that studies that
had more statistical power were more
likely to show a positive effect so you
know you're not talking about a night
and day difference on blood pressure
control if it's a relatively short term
relatively small study
where people aren't doing that much more
walking uh walking a bit more probably
isn't going to have much of a measurable
effect on blood pressure but the longer
studies where people walked a bit more
sample sizes were a bit larger
did tend to pretty reliably find
improvements on blood pressure from
walking interventions
and that can be a generally important
note as you're reviewing literature
because um you know there was a recent
study that helms talked about in in mass
where some researchers were looking at
time restricted feeding over the course
of like i think it was like eight weeks
and
within the eight-week study they were
like oh this is great no impact on fat
free mass or lean mass secretion looks
like the two are more or less
interchangeable for that outcome
but
obviously eight weeks is a really short
span of time or you know even if it were
12 weeks you know
the longer you do an intervention if you
continuously apply it the more those
groups have an opportunity to diverge
and separate
and so those researchers checked in on
the same participants or a sub-sample of
them a year later
and they did see divergent effects for
fat-free mass and so
you have to be really cautious with some
of these shorter studies you might see
one or two studies that are short and
say oh it looks like this intervention
didn't work then you look at a meta and
say well no they were getting there and
then when we look at the longer studies
we see where they were
where they were headed what kind of a
trajectory they were on yeah yeah for
sure
uh okay so moving on a meta-analysis by
richards or by richardson and colleagues
a meta-analysis of pedometer-based
walking interventions and weight loss uh
so
this was a
meta looking at randomized control
trials and prospective cohort studies uh
with pedometer-based interventions so
uh it wasn't all rcts included in this
meta there were some prospective cohort
studies but there's still an
intervention here like they're giving
people pedometers and encouraging them
to walk more
um so that that's still
uh stronger evidence than just purely
just a purely observational uh
prospective cohort study
uh so nine studies met the inclusion
criteria for this meta
um and they found that there was a
small effect of pedometer based walking
interventions on weight loss
across the nine studies people lost
about one and a quarter kilos of body
mass on average
uh with longer interventions being
associated with greater total weight
change and on average participants lost
about 0.05 kilograms per week during the
interventions
and one thing i'll note is that that
doesn't sound like a particularly large
change but
you know we're talking about an
intervention that has cumulative effects
over time and over time
during people's adult lives on average
what you tend to see is body weights
gradually drifting up over time
so if a pedometer based walking
intervention can basically have the
opposite effect you know you're not
seeing a night and day difference where
people lose 20 kilograms right away but
instead of a gradual trend up over time
you're seeing a gradual trend down over
time
that is
in in all likelihood a
positive effect that is likely to
improve general health
uh then moving on a systematic review
and meta-analysis by robertson and
colleagues walking for depression or
depressive symptoms a systematic review
and meta-analysis
so there were eight trials included here
um they found that walking interventions
uh improved um
depression related symptoms with a mean
pooled effect size of 0.86 which is
generally considered a large effect
they did note that there was quite a bit
of heterogeneity between the
interventions used in the studies they
looked at the research populations and
the magnitudes of effects observed in
those studies so
you know
i would always say uh when talking about
literature like this
don't we're not psychologists we're not
psychiatrists don't take anything we say
related to mental health as anything
approaching a prescription and that is
doubly true here because the authors of
this meta-analysis themselves say like
you know this this isn't a
one-size-fits-all thing we don't know
what the correct dosage is seems to
depend on the population but in general
they're finding
that
walking more tends to have a generally
beneficial effect on depression and
depressive symptoms
and you know mental health is
an important component of overall health
and they're finding in this
meta-analysis that walking more tends to
help with that as well
did they happen to i don't know if you
recall uh did they happen to point out
any particular
characteristics um
that seem to be driving some of that
heterogeneity
i don't remember for sure because i
prepped this segment two weeks ago yeah
that's my fault i'll take that no that's
fine but you know one of the things i
think about is you know
certainly i would expect that dose
matters um where
you want to have enough walking that
you're you know really doing something
but also not so much when we're talking
about you know mental health outcomes
that it becomes a stressor you know that
it's too ambitious a goal and it's kind
of stressing you out to try to keep up
with the walking prescription well and
depression itself tends to cause
generalized fatigue so you probably
wouldn't want to be walking so much that
you're feeding into that yeah and and i
also wonder
how much of the heterogeneity could
potentially be related to the walking
environment um and this is total
speculation we're going to get into that
oh cool okay then i won't i won't jump
ahead well indirectly indirectly because
like what i think about is like if you
tell me hey give me you know 9 000 steps
on this treadmill in a crowded gym pass
yeah you know but if you say hey check
out this lovely park you want to stroll
through the woods absolutely i'll do
that all day yeah yeah
um yeah i'm going to touch on that a
little bit later
i'll note i didn't get too far into the
details of this meta-analysis mostly
because
since i'm not a mental health
professional uh i would i would not have
wanted to provide so many details that
it began to sound like a prescription
yeah uh even if i was very explicit that
it's not um
but yeah i i do think you're probably on
the right track there yeah um okay so uh
moving on um
here here was another meta-analysis of
prospective cohort studies much like the
giyetti meta that we started off with uh
but there there's an important uh factor
in this that i want to mention so um
walking and primary prevention a
meta-analysis of prospective cohort
studies by hamer
and colleagues
so basically this was a meta-analysis
looking at prospective cohort studies um
on walking and their influence on
cardiovascular disease risk and
mortality rates
and the thing i want to point out here
is that
there were 18 prospective cohort studies
included almost half a million total
participants and here's the important
part
the participants in the in the
prospective cohort studies were free
from cardiovascular disease at baseline
and then about 20 000 of them had some
form of cardiovascular disease at
follow-up uh so the important bit is
that
these were
people who did not have cardiovascular
disease at baseline and the the
criticism was like well uh of the of the
jetty meta was i like well you know
we're seeing that
we're seeing lower rates of all-cause
mortality in people who walk more but
maybe that is just a proxy for disease
state where people who
already have some sort of chronic
disease maybe walk less and that uh in
and that's influencing the mortality
rate scene so in in this meta-analysis
by hamer and colleagues the subjects
were free of cardiovascular disease at
baseline um and they were looking at
rates at follow-up and they basically
found that uh walking interventions
tended to reduce risks uh your risk of
developing cardiovascular disease by
about 30 percent uh give or take um
yeah so
like like i said that's that's not an
rct i just wanted to point that out
because it because
also a meta on perspective cohort
studies but specifically in disease-free
individuals at baseline still finding
that
walking tended to be associated with
with lower rates of cardiovascular
disease
origination
and then let's see in terms of
potential
mechanisms i would say
uh this wasn't a meta-analysis this this
is a
a narrative review by coyle and
colleagues uh published very recently uh
in exercise and sport science reviews if
memory serves title is inactivity causes
resistance to improvements in metabolism
after exercise
this was this was a cool uh review paper
that i'd recommend checking out
basically what the authors here do is
they go through several studies
finding that the acute effects
the the acute metabolic effects of
exercise
tend to be blunted
in people who are more inactive at
baseline so
um you know if you put people if you put
people on on the treadmill for an hour
what you
expect to see is increased fat oxidation
reduced plasma triglycerides better
glucose control etc etc and you do tend
to see those things on average but
you tend to see them more reliably and
more robustly in people who are just
generally more active at baseline people
who spend less total sedentary time or
just
average more steps per day and i think
in general
you might anticipate to see the opposite
um you know people who are
i would say kind of more relatively
untrained who are less active you might
expect to see larger acute improvements
in those variables when you actually
make them exercise a little bit uh but
it's actually the opposite so people who
have higher rates of baseline activity
tend to see larger acute improvements in
those metabolic variables after
uh acute
aerobic exercise and so that that might
be a potential mechanism
underlying
some of these observations
and then finally this is this is kind of
the clincher
and i'll note one of the reasons that
the criticism that like oh like you guys
are just mistaking correlation with
causation one of the reasons that that
criticism of
like the stronger by science content
about the meta frustrated me a little
bit
is the meta that i'm about to talk about
was cited in the review on the website i
think a lot of people just missed this
and and this will also get to the
um
the circumstances of walking like you
mentioned before
so title is is there evidence that
walking groups have health benefits a
systematic review and meta-analysis by
hanson and jones
and so this was a meta-analysis on
um
on intervention studies with adult
walking groups outdoors so i didn't know
that this was such a robust uh area of
research
largely because like i don't know i i
tend to focus on
exercise physiology and and strength
stuff and not necessarily like public
health interventions but i think this is
pretty popular in research like in the
uk
where uh you know they just
get a bunch of adults and they're like
hey why don't you guys get together and
walk through the park for a little bit
and we'll see if that does anything good
uh so there were 42 studies that met the
inclusion criteria for this
meta-analysis uh and and like i said
they were all adult subjects and it was
outdoor walking groups you get together
with you know maybe half a dozen a dozen
people
and you just stroll through the park for
you know 30 minutes an hour and not a
particularly intense pace
and uh all of the studies
included in this meta-analysis lasted
for a year or less so they're relatively
short-term studies
everything i'm about to talk about you
don't necessarily need to do it for five
years to start seeing improvements uh so
all of the interventions lasted a year
or less
and they led to significant decreases in
systolic blood pressure diastolic blood
pressure resting heart rate body fat
percentage body mass index total
cholesterol
depression scores on a on a standard
like depression symptoms inventory uh
increased vo2 max increased six minute
walk distance and score on the sf 36
physical functioning inventory which is
basically just asking like kind of how
much you struggle with activities of
daily living stuff like that um
but yeah so uh
essentially they found that if you get
outside with your homies
and walk a little bit not even that much
a few times a week 30 minutes for an
hour uh within a year that can reduce
10 different risk factors for all calls
mortality which is uh
pretty striking i think um and like you
mentioned is
i
you can't necessarily attribute
the findings of this meta-analysis
solely to walking like there could be a
social component since it was all group
based might be influenced just by
getting folks outside a bit more
but the
the bulk of the intervention itself was
a walking intervention
um
so yeah all of which is to say
i
do think that the
population level associations we see
between walking and all-cause mortality
i do think it's far more than mere
association
there's a lot of evidence that walking
interventions modify known risk factors
of mortality specifically uh
cardiovascular disease mortality um
and
yeah like it's it's not just uh i don't
think it's a mere association and uh the
reason i brought up the coil paper about
inactivity causing
resistance to
acute
metabolic changes post exercise is i do
think i think one of the reasons that i
got a bit of pushback about that meta
is i think that a lot of people who
exercise quite a bit um
want to believe that that
picks all of the
uh activity-related boxes when it comes
to overall health um
and i think there's a reason that people
want to believe that like i want to
believe that i have a sedentary job i
work on a computer uh you know i go for
a few walks i lift weights i play some
basketball
but
i mean eight hours a day i'm sitting on
my ass uh reading writing typing
whatever um so i
i very much want to think that that is
not having deleterious general health
effects it probably is um i don't know
what i gained from lying to myself about
that
but yeah so i think that's one of the
reasons why there was a bit of pushback
like um
you know if you have an office job and
you go work out for an hour every day
after work but maybe you're only
averaging three four thousand steps per
day um
you don't necessarily want to think that
it takes a while to get steps in you
know like if you if you
uh live in a commuter culture where
there's not great public transit uh
you're driving an hour to and from work
every day you work a sedentary job boom
there's 10 hours of the day gone uh you
sleep eight hours a night boom there's
18 hours of the day gone now you got six
hours left you need to eat some meals
you want to spend some time with loved
ones
you have some hobbies uh and you know if
you want to work in
ten thousand steps at some at some point
in that process uh that aren't
facilitated by your lifestyle like if
you don't live in a walkable city or
something like that um
you know it's gonna take a while like
it's gonna take a significant time
investment to get those steps in
and so
it would be
great
if that wasn't necessary and you could
just go to the gym for an hour boom now
you've checked all of those boxes um but
at least my my read of the literature is
that that is not the case uh that just
overall general activity levels with
step counts being a pretty good proxy
for that um
does seem to be not only a
predictor of of general health and
longevity but probably a causal factor
as well um and yeah it would be i would
love if that was not the case uh and for
for years i told myself that that wasn't
the case um
but yeah as as i've got into this
literature more i've
uh unfortunately for myself changed my
mind about that
yeah and i'm not um super deep into this
literature but
i am aware of literature that
might
be a breath of fresh air to people who
are a little bit concerned about the
time required to get some of these more
ambitious step counts like
you describe the scenario where
you know you start running out of hours
of the day there aren't that many
opportunities to say i'm gonna go walk
for 90 minutes and really chip away at
this step count but there's kind of this
separate body of literature which
focuses more on just breaking up your
sedentary time so
even if it's a struggle and you can't
say where am i going to clear out two
hours to do all this walking
there are likely independent benefits of
saying well i can't do that but
you know at my job
uh you know it depends on your your work
environment and what you do for a living
but there are many sedentary office type
jobs where you can say every hour
i can take maybe three minutes
step away from my desk go to the
stairwell you know do a couple flights
up and down go back to my desk you know
just breaking up instead of having an
eight-hour block of sedentary time if
you can break that up into
eight
sedentary one hour blocks with just a
little bit of activity in between that
seems to be helpful
you know to what extent that's going to
allow you to hit these type of step
counts i don't know but but it seems
like if you're just like well what the
hell am i going to do like i don't have
time there are
ways that you can kind of divide this up
throughout the day and at least try to
break up those really extended blocks of
sedentary time yeah yeah and i think i
think that um so one like you mentioned
there's research on that but two i mean
like anecdotally um
i think a lot of people experience that
when you go from college to work because
you know if you
go to college on a campus where maybe
you're taking classes all day but
classes are
45 minutes long and then you've got to
walk depending on the size of the campus
five to 10 minutes across campus to go
to your next class that's functionally
what you're doing like you're you're
very sedentary for
the better part of an hour and then you
know you're somewhat active for five ten
minutes uh and
i mean i can tell you for myself when i
got out of college uh
even though the total time i spent work
the total time i spent working did
increase but it wasn't like a huge just
you know now now i'm sedentary for four
times as much time it it really was like
hey total sedentary time is comparable
but now i i don't have these kind of
built-in hourly breaks to stretch my
legs and walk around a little bit
man over the span of like six months i
started feeling so much more like [ __ ]
and just so much older
um
which is funny to say looking back on it
because i feel so much older now that i
did
at uh at 22. but uh yeah i mean
i i think a lot of people experience
that just from going from a college
campus to
a sedentary job like
total sedentary time may not change all
that much but once you remove those
hourly breaks to stretch your legs i
think a lot of people do just kind of
feel worse for it
so yeah you can reverse that
if you're if your job and situation
allows for it
just every hour getting up stretching
your legs a little bit
doing something slightly active walking
around if you can i gotta say that's one
of the things that i think that overall
the reduction in in smoking in our
society probably a good thing but
one one of the things that was probably
pretty clutch when everyone smoked is
just like
half of your office would need to take
hourly smoke breaks and so then like if
you don't smoke you you could be like oh
man yeah i'm going out to burn one and
then just like do a lap around the block
i don't think you can really get away
with that as much anymore because not as
many people smoke all of which is to say
convince your co-workers to start
smoking again for your health
that's really good advice
i'm glad you were so cautious about
giving psychology advice but then you're
having people convince all their
coworkers
i i am not convincing anyone to smoke
i'm telling someone else to step beyond
their scope of practice
i mean we live in north carolina like
this is a state built on tobacco yeah
for the good of the economy we kind of
need it yeah for sure
yeah um
we we
i used to be so spoiled with trying to
get uh non-exercise physical activity
because
like i couldn't
i couldn't afford a campus parking pass
um like they're they're quite expensive
uh where we went to grad school
but the campus was beautiful it's a very
uh
a very mild climate most seas like you
know you could walk
most of the year without feeling like
it's frigid outside so man i would walk
to work i'd walk home from work i'd walk
to the gym i would you know you're on
campus so you have to walk to class walk
to the lab all your meetings you're
walking i used to get so many steps
without even thinking about it and then
went through the same thing where it's
like oh now i just work from my
apartment on a computer and man it was
so hard to try to get even a fraction of
the steps i used to get
and the implications for that i mean you
know you went through all the meta
analyses of all these different health
related parameters and even things
related to
mental health outcomes
but it's not just that you know so like
last episode i talked a lot about energy
audits
and i've had several
one-on-one calls where i chat with
somebody we do an energy audit and
more often than not the first piece of
advice i give you know we'll we'll do
some things with the diet and with some
tracking changes and things like that
but
in most cases the first thing i i
identify is we have a lot of sedentary
time and very minimal
physical activity outside of the gym so
one of my first recommendations is let's
see how frequently we can do a little
bit of exercise like non-exercise
physical activity and let's see if we
can push this step count a little bit
higher so this stuff relates to body
composition as well
especially when you find people who are
really struggling with some of that
stubborn fat loss this can be the type
of intervention that gets you over the
hump and gets things moving uh in the
right direction and i believe if memory
serves
i believe several months ago
if not years ago
helms covered a paper
uh looking at athletes um who are who
were currently engaged in competitive
sport
and even among those athletes i believe
their uh
their sedentary time was correlated with
some of their body composition outcomes
yeah so you know like you said a lot of
people like to believe because it would
be extremely convenient listen i do my
hour a day in the gym you know four or
five days a week and i i that should
have me covered but even in these really
competitive athletes there was still an
additive effect of some of this
uh sedentary time that you know we could
break that up outside of the gym by
having some of this extra activity
and another factor
aside from body composition and energy
balance um i remember back in the day
before i was even involved with stronger
by science you had an article
that touched on uh
how in some cases
a
lack of
aerobic capacity could potentially
uh interfere with one's ability to train
effectively and recover effectively from
training is that still a perspective
that you hold like do you think that
relates to this conversation
i i think it does um i i think that it
yeah so i
two things one i i definitely think it
relates to recovery um
so
generally being active or even like
doing some like intentional low
intensity aerobic training uh can can
help
with um
with like sympathetic versus
parasympathetic nervous system
modulation um like if you do a really
hard strength training workout and then
you're you're very sedentary afterwards
um
for some people sometimes like your
sympathetic nervous system can kind of
stay a little bit more keyed up which um
like i i don't wanna
i don't wanna make too sweeping of
claims but that that can
make it take a little bit longer to kind
of shift into
relax and recover mode whereas like if
you
lift and then maybe just like go for a
walk or something like that it does help
bring you back down um
which might be good from a recovery
perspective as far as the like work
capacity stuff goes i i do think that
that's mostly in the domain of people
who are already like quite strong
um
mostly just because like the
the energy cost of a set of training you
do is pretty dependent on the amount of
weight on the bar so like if you squat
250 pounds for 10 reps that burns about
half as much energy as squatting 500 for
10 reps
and then
if you're crazy strong you can squat 750
for 10 reps that's burning like three
times as much energy in about the same
period of time as squatting 250 for 10
reps
and when you actually do that math you
can
you can wind up uh
if you're strong enough
you can be burning through energy at a
rate that is comparable comparable to
like sprinting 200 400 meters and you
know it is so if you're
not that strong yet and you're like oh
man like i can i can do a set of 10
squatting at like 135 and like i feel
fine afterwards like why why do the
strong people at my gym seem dead after
they do tens it's like i head out to a
track sprint 400 meters like that's
that's what they feel like um
so uh yeah i mean
i i do think that
lack of aerobic fitness might become a
bottleneck on how hard you can train
once you get strong enough
um
which which probably does describe a
non-trivial amount of our listeners but
i i don't think most people acutely need
to worry about that all that much yeah
yeah cool but yeah when it comes to
walking and just kind of building up
that
base of aerobic fitness and getting more
physical activity and if you can add on
top of that
doing it outside in a lovely environment
with people you enjoy spending time with
uh there's such a wide range of benefits
you know it's one of those things that
there's so much to gain from it
and as long as it can be feasibly
implemented you know it's kind of a
win-win situation for sure
all right so
before we wrap up the show i have a very
brief uh answer that i want to give to a
listener question this actually came
from the macro factor group we have a
facebook group
where macro factor users
ask all sorts of questions and support
each other it's a really nice group a
lot of really positive helpful people in
there
the question was uh
how much should i stress
over a pre-bed protein feeding
and this is a common thing a lot of
times people will say
i got to the end of the day
i was pretty close to my calorie target
my protein was pretty much met for the
day but like should i be
carving out extra room so i have a a
protein feeding right before bed
and i think probably the best single
resource for this is a review paper by
snyder's and colleagues published in
2019 i'll link it in the show notes here
it was called the impact of pre-sleep
protein ingestion
on the skeletal muscle adaptive response
to exercise in humans colon and update
and the biggest thing that really stuck
out to me in this review is that there
is surprisingly not that much
longitudinal research
on pre-bed protein feedings and the
research we do have there are quite a
few studies that have a pretty key
limitation that has a huge uh a huge
impact on how we interpret those
findings so there was a paper in 2015 by
the same author group snyders and
colleagues
and um
the title of the paper was protein
ingestion before sleep increases muscle
mass and strength gains during prolonged
resistance type exercise training in
healthy young men and so they they gave
it away there basically um the nighttime
protein the pre-bed protein
intervention was 27.5 grams of protein
it was a mixture of casein and casein
hydrolysate
but the really important thing so
obviously over 12 weeks of lifting they
found these benefits for muscle mass
they found these benefits for strength
gains
but the interventions were not protein
matched and they were not energy matched
and so
the the group that was getting this
extra protein at bed
they are right before bed it was bumping
them from 1.3 grams per kilogram per day
or that that was the protein intake in
the placebo group
but the the pre-bed protein group they
were eating like 1.9 grams per kilogram
per day so so there was a big
discrepancy between the groups in terms
of total protein intake um and so
basically what they were really looking
at is does giving people below the the
typical optimal range does giving them
extra protein and extra calories help
with
gaining muscle gaining strength that's
very different from hey should i be
shifting more protein to a pre-bed
feeding or adding more protein feedings
to the day
there was a study by antonio and
colleagues that i'll link in the show
notes
where you know they investigated this
pre uh pre-bed protein feeding
but they did it differently so
they looked at changes in fat-free mass
gains one group was getting protein
supplemented in the evening the other
was supplementing the same amount of
protein same calories in the morning
and they did not find statistically
significant differences uh they they did
find differences that i guess leaned in
favor of the uh the evening protein
feeding so they gained 1.2 kilograms of
fat free mass whereas the group getting
protein in the morning gained 0.4
kilograms
but i mean that's that's not i mean it
wasn't statistically significant and
when you look at typical
uh body composition measurement devices
that's really not enough where you'd say
hey there's got to be something here i
mean that that's well within the range
of just kind of measurement error
sampling error things like that
there was a paper by joy and colleagues
which i'll link below
where they found no significant
differences in muscle mass
or the gains in muscle mass following 10
weeks of lifting
and basically they were looking at
again comparing night time versus
daytime supplementation
with casein protein
there were it was a pretty small sample
but again it was another instance where
looking at giving the same protein
supplement morning versus before bed
it just didn't seem to have a
particularly notable effect so quick
conclusions if you are
wondering about this idea of pre-bed
protein um
you know it's a great opportunity to get
a protein feeding right before bed but
the research would not indicate that
there's anything particularly special
about night time when it comes to
protein we just need to make sure that
we get enough discrete protein feedings
throughout the day
and there is some research some very
applied research suggesting that when
you jump from two sufficient protein
boluses to three
in a given day there are some benefits
there when it comes to strength
adaptations and gaining fat free mass
and muscle mass so i think you can make
a really good evidence-based argument
not just based on mechanisms but based
on applied evidence that you're better
off getting at least three protein
feedings that are adequate in size
compared to only two of them but there's
also research showing that when we jump
up from three to six
there's not a particularly large
difference so from my perspective i
think if you're only getting two protein
feedings throughout the day
you probably will benefit from getting a
third protein dose that's at least
0.25 maybe 0.3 grams of protein per
kilogram of body mass
whether or not that's coming right
before bed doesn't seem to be that
critical you just want to get at least
three protein servings that are spread
throughout the day
and another conclusion relates more to
protein selection
one of the things i find really
interesting is that people get really
really into
the
the rate of protein digestion when they
talk about this pre-bed time window
um and people will say well you got to
go with the slow digesting protein
because it's it's before bed and you
need those amino acids to stay elevated
overnight so that you can do more
protein synthesis overnight but as we
all know casein is the most slowly
digesting protein in existence is it not
uh it is not what yeah it's pretty
pretty incredible are you telling me
that the last decade of supplement
marketing has been has been misleading
me i
i'm not telling you anything but that
sounds accurate to me um yeah so protein
digestion speed everybody says well
weighs fast casein is slow take casein
before bed there's really not strong
evidence to suggest that casein is
special
as a pre-bed protein source like you
said it's not that slow on the spectrum
of proteins it's just slower than whey
which is a very fast protein in terms of
digestion and absorption speed so the
whole casein thing there's not really
great evidence to suggest that you'd be
better off with pre-bed casein versus
pre-bed
whey or pre-bed egg protein which is
actually
way slower in terms of digestion speed
than than casein so that's one thing to
keep in mind but i also kind of push
back against the premise um so
one of the kind of our mechanistic
understanding of muscle protein
synthesis
is that uh
when we ingest dietary protein uh and we
have a dose large enough to maximize
muscle protein synthesis muscle protein
synthesis those rates are going to spike
and then they're going to start to taper
off
and the rate at which they taper off
does not seem to to be dependent on the
persistent uh level of blood amino acid
levels you know
there seems to be some kind of temporal
component where even if um
you know blood levels of amino acids
remain very high protein synthesis is
going to spike and then fall
regardless of those amino acid levels
it's not like if we just have a
sustained level of you know a slower
kind of rate of appearance that we're
going to prolong that muscle protein
synthesis response to a meaningful
degree so i kind of push back against
this idea that this is the one window
where we have to really micromanagement
or where we have to really micromanage
that
in terms of um
managing muscle protein synthesis itself
like that the whole time course of
digestion and absorption uh
that that doesn't seem very uh
compelling to me as an argument now some
people might say well you're you're
ignoring muscle protein breakdown you
need to focus more on that but you know
you could look at other research
comparing fast and slow proteins
and you know the effect on
net muscle protein accretion seems to be
pretty similar with the fast versus the
slow uh protein sources in many cases
they just follow a slightly different
time course you know so
you could look at a really fast
digesting protein consumed in a fasted
state with no previous meals and say
okay there's a huge spike in protein
synthesis
you know all of that kind of muscle
remodeling and protein accretion happens
over a quicker time course looking at
the slower proteins the initial spike in
muscle protein synthesis might be
delayed it might not be quite as high
but looking at the total net protein
accretion over the next you know six
seven eight hours it just doesn't seem
to matter that much
but probably the biggest reason that i
don't like to micromanage protein
sources
is related to one of the the kind of
details i included in that previous
statement i mentioned consumed in a
fasted state you know with basically
with no other foods no other beverages
that's really important because
um
this conversation becomes a lot less
exciting the conversation about protein
sources when you recognize that
digestion speed is going to be impacted
by previous meals it's going to be
impacted by co-ingestion of other
nutrients so like even if you wanted to
really
stress over your protein sources um and
i don't think you should when you look
at the direct studies comparing
way versus casein longitudinally uh
studies comparing different like
titrated doses of a mixture of whey in
casein to modulate the digestion speed
when you look at egg whites versus egg
yolks and how those have different
digestion speeds but ultimately have
similar body comp changes over time i
don't think we should be worried about
those in the first place but then when
you consider the fact that like whatever
you ate at 6 p.m is going to impact
digestion speed for what you have at 9
00 pm before bed
and if instead of having just a way
shake or a casing shake you also have
some source of fat and carbohydrate and
fiber with it all of that stuff about
digestion speed gets altered in a way
that is context dependent so
the short version of this is
if pre-bed is an opportunity for you to
go from
insufficient protein feedings to
adequate protein feedings you know if
that's what it takes to get you
up to that third you know sufficiently
sized dose for the day great
or if you struggle to meet your daily
protein goal and a pre-bed protein
feeding helps you get to that daily goal
again that's fantastic i don't think we
need to be hyper worried or stressed
over the pre-bed feeding opportunity
it's a great opportunity but there's no
evidence to suggest that it is a
extremely unique opportunity for
supporting body comp changes and
all of the
arguments about the perfect pre-bed
protein dose
i think
there's insufficient evidence to support
casein as this like perfect pre-bed
protein
and i think the general premise is
really weakened when you consider the
fact that you are still digesting
probably multiple meals from earlier in
the day so the digestion speeds are
going to be heavily impacted by other
factors
so hopefully that wraps uh wraps up that
question
and now to play us out uh greg i
understand that you've got a segment
that you're excited about uh some really
terrific content yes uh so
i'm sure many listeners of this podcast
want to know more information about the
one and only host of this podcast mr
eric trexler yeah um
and a a intrepid reporter named anne
for the
uh as best i can tell
research-based website faxbuddy.com
was also interested in
uh in in data and information about eric
so she put together a really nice
profile of him based on
i can only imagine very
in-depth sourcing government documents
tax records etc etc um
to really help you
get to know
all of the intimate details uh about
eric's life so she reached out to me for
an interview but i declined because i i
really
enjoy living a very private life yeah
we'll we'll get into that yeah uh so
okay uh
eric trek's eric trexler's bio uh looks
to be exactly what is printed on his bio
on the stronger by science website so i
i think i know the source for that
uh eric's age
eric was born in the united states but
he loves to keep his personal life
secretive hence trexler has not
mentioned any details concerning his
exact birth details to the public
uh i just love that wording he he loves
to keep his personal life secretive not
just he chooses to do it he loves
nothing he get he gets off on secrecy
folks it's a thing i like to withhold
information yeah yeah uh eric trexler
height uh eric is a man of above average
stature uh true trexler stands at a
height of 5 foot 11 inches um
and yeah so that's a good thing to know
if you've ever seen a picture of eric at
like a conference or something with
other people in the fitness industry and
you've gotten the idea that he may be
slightly shorter than average that's
actually incorrect most people don't
know this the vast majority of people in
the fitness industry are at least like
six four six five um but yeah eric is is
five eleven basically especially natural
bodybuilding there's a lot of very tall
people oh yeah huge huge people well i
mean it's it's the classic decision uh
early in people's lives like am i good
enough to make it to the nba or do i
veer off and do natural bodybuilding
yeah um
let's see what some other good stuff
education seems to be accurate uh yeah
let's just let's just jump to the money
shot if you've ever wondered how much
money you can make by by founding and
being the one and only host of the first
and only fitness podcast uh
let's see trexler is
a phd pro bodybuilder researcher and
coach correspondent therefore trexler
earns a decent a decent salary as a phd
pro bodybuilder researcher and coach
and uh
co-owner of stronger buy science i i
and you know so it's worth noting this
isn't all podcast income he does make
pretty good money as a pro bodybuilder
that's that's a good chunk of it we all
do
that's why you do natural but i hate
bodybuilding but for the money yeah i
can't i can't turn it down so according
to fax buddy and i assume the irs as
well trexler's average salary is
721
223 dollars per year um
so you know it's based on good
documented evidence and sources since
they have it down to the dollar
which is which is nice
um
yeah so we'll we'll link this in the
show notes uh if you
would have any interest in in learning
more about eric
so uh yeah check it out but i don't want
people to get um
incorrect expectations and change their
professional goals and trajectory like
don't quit your job to become a
podcaster because a lot of that uh what
was that seven eight hundred thousand
dollars a year yeah a lot of that was
because we did it first
you know so like i i don't know if if
you'd still get that benefit where you
know i'm sure there
people who make fitness podcasts now
they might only be making like 500 600
grand a year yeah yeah that's so so i
don't want people to miscalculate that
expectation and quit their job the
moment they hear this yeah but but it is
also worth noting so i i looked to see
who else ann had profiled uh for for the
research-based website factsbuddy.com
um
and i i think it's worth noting how much
more money there is in podcasting than
say writing best-selling books or
selling bulletproof coffee so she also
did a profile of dave asprey
and uh you know you look at him from the
outside and you're like man this guy has
built an empire for himself turns out he
actually only makes about 76 grand a
year so uh
you know if you're thinking too much to
yourself like do i hire an agent um put
together pitches to a major publisher
try to write a couple best-selling books
or start a podcast uh you know those
those are kind of the two options you're
going to make 10 times as much money
starting a podcast um
so yeah you got to go for that
yeah
i i'm really
i really appreciate the fact that
there's people reporting the real facts
about uh
my uh
you know above average height and very
above average wealth i appreciate that
um
but given the fact that it is uh
mid-march if if anyone listening works
for the irs
that that income number is not correct
uh i just think it's important to
clarify that before the uh april tax
debt well that's that's total income
counting
income you've made in the cayman islands
and monaco
so that is not his taxable income that's
total income two very different things
yeah uh as soon as soon as the paradise
papers to come out
we'll we'll be able to fully unravel the
the trexler economic and business empire
yeah yeah that website is terrific we
are going through a bunch of different
uh
noteworthy fitness people last night
um and i just cannot fathom where any of
that information comes from aside from
as far as i can tell you have the
highest income in the entire fitness
industry uh
the same website has steffy cohen making
61 grand a year which
i am positive is incorrect uh
yeah the i also have a question steffi
and dave were the two where i was like
yeah no
i i also question um
the just inability to get my age i'm
sure we've mentioned it
70 times on the podcast oh for sure for
sure the idea that i live this ultra
private life
we did a whole series of like 10
fireside chats where it's like why don't
we talk about our personal lives yeah
you know but anyway uh yeah hard-hitting
reporting there by anne
and uh yeah we will link it in the show
notes and i hope that you don't get a
virus from clicking on it
all right so that does it for this
episode as always thank you for
listening and we'll be back in a week
with another one
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you